in the digital age people take pictures  quickly whether with a camera or on a  smartphone and quality doesn't matter  much photo platforms like Instagram and  Tumblr simply call them bad pictures but  if you want to take a really good  picture you should take a look at  Arsenal the app controlled camera  assistant is meant to help amateur  photographers capture the perfect shot  on digital single-lens reflex cameras  they offer countless settings but using  them is complicated the Arsenal app can  be controlled from a smartphone  artificial intelligence helps you adjust  up to 18 different settings for the  perfect photo or time-lapse video more  than a million euros have been poured  into the crowdfunding project on  Kickstarter Arsenal is set to be ready  for delivery 2018